y'a pas de blague dans camelot du zéro
blague ya pas de blague n'y a pas de
gagner pas de méchants c'est chiant qui
voit la camelote c'est chiant c'est
triste
10 à cirer ce jour de colère le court
métrage que j'ai fait il ya vingt ans
maintenant qui se passe uniquement
autour de la table ronde s'appelait dies
irae et camelot ça finit par être quand
même beaucoup plus parlant dans
l'histoire du truc parce que c'est le
parce que c'est la forteresse d'arthur
me rendant compte que les gens disaient
camelot parce qu'avec un seul tjr foutu
un deuxième pour forcer les gens à dire
camelot parce que cam nou mèm pa
oui c'est un oui c'est vrai moi je
possède une terre en écosse on m'a
offert un mètre carré avec un arbre en
écosse donc a priori je suis lord
écossais parce que j'ai de la terre en
écosse j'aurai le droit de le porter je
n'use pas de ce droit
quotidiennement
vrai oui vrai je savais qu'il est mais
j'ai appris qu'il aimait un camelot
parce qu'il était son équipe était
passée à la production pour demander les
épisodes de la série pour pour partir
avec dans son pack entertainment
j'étais très fier d'en faire partie bien
entendu mais je me suis dit puisqu'il
est là haut peut-être il aime bien il va
louper il va louper le fils hugo gagner
non donc je vais proposer mais à lui
tout seul un message privé de voir le
truc c'est là une aire de voile alors
après évidemment les fans se dit ah et
si vous voyez le film bah oui mais
d'accord mais ça vraiment n'occupe
oui moi je pense que le mieux ses films
séries films
assistez bassiste je me suis toujours
débrouillé pour écrire les musiques de
tout ce que je faisais donc je n'ai
jamais lâché
oui oui oui non bah si je pouvais me
dédoubler ça irait plus vite
qu'est-ce que
des comptes je déteste je déteste le
terme de blague c'est comme gags barque
j'ai pas du tout envie de faire des
trucs comme ça
ah non non non non non je préfère non il
n'y a pas de blague dans kent autrichien
qui voit la camelote c'est chiant c'est
triste
c'est vrai la série
tu est entièrement dédié à louis de
funès ce que je pouvais faire de mieux
en hommage à celui qui m'a filé en 8 de
faire de la comédie populaire j'ai dit
j'essayais de lui dédier un gros truc
arabe et c'est pas énorme mais enfin
c'est ce que j'ai pu pour moi c'est
toute la série
c'est faux c'est tellement ça me fait
quand ces choses sont trop faux ses
douleurs je sais que des gens qui
confondent un peu parce qu'ils disent
est le roi des bretons c'est pas le roi
des bretons il ya une grande bretagne et
une petite bretagne et surtout le
royaume qui nous concerne s'appelle le
royaume de l'ogre et ce royaume s'étend
du nord de l'île de bretagne en écosse
là où calédonie à l'époque et ça descend
jusqu'à la frontière aquitaine qui est
qu'ils sont en prendre sous des pyrénées
et pas de retard j'ai pas de date mais
je suis pas je suis foutu chef de garage
et pas des horaires merde à la fois un
nom jésus il arrive quand ils arrivent
c'est tout
ne faites pas ça chez vous ah non je ne
prends pas la responsabilité des
maximonstres postérité comme ça mais moi
j'y suis pour rien j'ai pas demandé de
la crème amo d'euros id pour mes yeux
c'est des trucs de maquilleuses dit ne
t'inquiète pas mieux je te met à grimper
mais robin sous les yeux ça va piquer un
peu
c'est faux
à part sting bien qu'il a eu beaucoup
plus tôt mais parce qu'il fallait qu'ils
apprennent ces répliques en français
donc il a eu d'ailleurs les scripts et
il a eu ma voix que j'ai enregistré ma
voix moi je coince personnes j'essaie
pas déjà parce que des fois les textes
les ai pas juste que je les ai pas fait
donc battu pour la renvoyer les époques
non pas mal en mer j'ai six enfants sur
sept qui ont qui ont joué dans kaamelott
le truc c'est que le 7e il est né
pendant la post prod du film donc je
peux pas venir je vais aller faire des
plans on ne trouve pas pour lui dans le
machin bon donc lui y est pas il sera
dans le prochain
voilà ma mère mon père il ferait remet
son sa mère oui oui des gens la fin on
était comédien ils sont cédés comédien
si je n'ai pas tiré d'une boulangerie ou
d'une charcuterie ils sont ils sont
c'est leur métier
non parce que je n'ai pas en dés c'était
avant moi parce que je trouve que c'est
simple à dire simple à écrire et le mec
qu'il écrive sur des panneaux de
manifestation une machin truc j'avoue
que j'aime beaucoup je suis content que
le public s'octroient des de la langue
j'aime bien que ce soit ça qu'ils aiment
la saga plus plus de sagard et